auch da ist mein auto frau motzkus
ja ich würde gerne haben wir extra
besorgt ich bin schnell wieder
zurückgeben der winter vermisst und der
sieht ja toll ab
[Musik]
lebte
sie beruhigen im grunde genommen haben
wir heute eine kaffeefahrt nur der
unterschied ist am ende bekommen sie was
möglich ist ich freue mich fest ich darf
ihnen zahn und ich freue mich dass ich
jetzt die infekte ja ja ja ich hatte
schon ein paar zweifel aber naja
zweifel wurden ist die nötigen müssen
nach vorne spielen haben sich die
impfstellen geworden also die jungs
haben probiert von morgens 10 besten hat
mir das um 3 und zwar bayern zum zuhause
am computer nähe am computer und mein
sohn in dransfeld mit drei monitoren das
sachen die müssen wir nochmal antrag hat
dass menschen nur in der lage sind dann
im termin zu bekommen wenn sie mir ihre
söhne haben und einer hat drei monitore
genau das müsse geändert werden
und der spanier sollte mal wirklich mal
mich anrufen vielleicht weil ich wusste
wie man einen impfstoff rankommen
connection oder nicht ganz oben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin hier sehr gerne war mir aber
eigentlich geht es auch darum dass sich
impfstoff pro ja und dann sage ich von
mir welchen abgeben so ein paar tropfen
oder so wir den das helfende dann müsste
ich was anderes einfallen lassen
ja man kann nicht sein dass sie mit
impfmittel rauskommen und ich nicht die
konzertsaison startet wieder
ja da freue ich mich vor allem auch
[Musik]
josef so konzerte gehe ich halt nicht
nennen was mögen sie an denn sie haben
die peter alexander
si
es ist ein horror
[Musik]
die
eine gute fahrt aber davon gibt es denn
punkte die sie besser machen würden als
herr laschet ich weiß nicht ob es auf
einen laster beziehen muss aber die man
nur vage über 80-jährige die zielgruppe
sind um sich online anzumelden
beispielsweise nachts schon gestellt
werden oder wenn wir alle briefen
informieren dass sie bald sich anmelden
können hätte man ja auch direkt einen
termin vergeben können und die dann eben
kein wollen die melden sich also ich
glaube es hätte schon an der eine andere
möglichkeit gegeben es etwas
komfortabler zu machen wie sie und ich
freue mich erstmals mit halbe-halbe
ausgefüllt habe ich sofort da wird schon
jemand kommt was wollen sie denn damit
das ist doch geheim zu daten dürfen sie
noch gar nicht lesen oder dafür wie weit
auch sie nicht krämer
ich glaube ich auch
das war super
lg herbert das will ich den ganzen geben
und mich freuen
das ist dürfen sich nein das ist nur ein
nein da bist du für sie das laut worden
waren das ist doch mal eine woche urlaub
machen
doch nicht nur deswegen sei es ist kommt
ja das ist ja könnte es helfen das waren
blut von geimpften personen trägt das
könnte helfen sollten wir mal zusammen
versuchen frau motzkus feria geimpft
ich bedanke mich und die kann mich jetzt
zu hause war wurde das super danke auch
so
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]